yeah great thank you i'm happy to be
here uh greetings from boston wish i
could be there in person
um as you see i'm there in spirit maybe
next year i'll manage to actually make
it over
um i'll share my screen to get started
one second to pull up my slides i'm
impressed by the decoration by the way
on point
thank you put some real thought into it
today
so um as mentioned i'm andrew terrio
i am a data science educator uh
consultant
um i think you know most notably for the
topic we're gonna get into today i used
to be the chief data officer of the city
of boston
for about two years i ran the city's
analytics team and you know was involved
in a lot of open data projects not only
with boston but with collaborations with
other cities
all around the world i also have spent
quite a few years working
in the political sector um i was at the
democratic national committee which is
in the u.s the
democratic party headquarters um i'm
also the co-organizer of the pi data
boston chapter so
uh you know this group is really near
and dear to me so
today what i want to talk about is the
intersection of civic data science
and open data we'll get into a bit
in a moment about what that means but i
want to talk about those in particular
because
as nicholas mentioned you know there's
often a challenge of
finding projects in the data science and
open source community
that really make great use of open data
and are long lasting and have a really
substantial impact
as i'll talk about you know we see a lot
of work being done with open data and
using open source tools
um but the number of those that actually
make it all the way to having
a major real-world impact is actually
pretty small and i think i've got a few
ideas why and i want to share them with
you today
so we're going to talk about what those
challenges are and i want to provide
a sense for everybody watching of you
know what it means to work with this
kind of data
how to design projects that are
effective and are successful at reaching
their goals
how to build partnerships with you know
governments and non-profits and others
that you need to really have that kind
of impact
and how to make the projects pay off
over the long term how to think
sustainably about you know what the
model
beyond just the initial release looks
like in order to
make sure that you actually have a
substantial impact
so just to get started i want to talk
about some sort of basics of what we're
discussing today
so this is the definition that i use for
civic data science it's the application
of data science methods
to support the work of governments
nonprofits advocacy groups political
campaigns
and other organizations which exist to
deliver positive social impact
and there are two things i like to focus
on here one is the idea of data science
methods i define that
really broadly so you know that's
everything from your basics of data
management and analysis to
all the way to predictive modeling ai
machine learning
you know all of the fancy tools that get
a lot of press i think the entire
spectrum really matters
um and you know i define data science
pretty broadly to just say
it's the scientific use of data to
accomplish a real world goal
the other part that i think is important
here is the last bit about
these organizations existing to deliver
positive social impacts
um i think it's an important distinction
to make when you compare it to the
commercial sector where
you know the goal of an organization is
to make money and maybe they have a
positive
social impact as well but ultimately the
motivations matter
and the reason i think civic data
science is important
number one is that i think these
organizations are really important
um because that is their main goal that
it's not just a byproduct of trying to
make money
that you know the entire focus of these
organizations is to promote
civic good and and i should note too um
you know when i talk about
social good or civic good um that is a
subjective definition what i consider
good is not necessarily the same thing
that one of you might
but you know overall the idea is uh
simply that
you're doing things for a reason other
than you know to make money
and and i think this is something where
the open source community is really tied
into i mean
when you're developing open source
software you know you're doing it to
enable
others to make use of it uh above and
beyond what you
you know yourself might actually make of
it and
that's something that's done for a
social good it's not just
being done for your own commercial gain
that's the opposite of open source
software
but i think what's really important
about civic data science particularly
is that there's a huge potential for
impact and the reason for that is simply
that
you know these kinds of organizations
tend to be uh
constrained in resources and that's
really the circumstance where data
science
is most vital and has the biggest impact
because through making things
more effective and efficient you're able
to really
help overcome some of those resource
challenges that those organizations face
but the other thing too i want to point
out is it's you know not just about
doing this sort of moral good in the
world um working on these kind of
projects is actually really exciting
um they're often fun to work on the
people you work with are really great
and there's a lot of opportunities to do
creative and innovative things
and you know all in all if you have a
chance to do it i'd highly recommend it
so open data well what is open data
you know there are many definitions you
could point to i think the key
factors that you should think about when
you're thinking about open data is that
it's data that's published in a public
forum that's available to everybody
and can be used for any purpose that
there's no restrictions on
what you can and can't use a given data
set for and ideally it's published in
some kind of you know machine
readable easy to use format um you know
the point there is once somebody
publishes it it's out there for anybody
to use for any purpose
and when we talk about it today i'm
mainly going to be focusing on
government published data
that's what i have a lot of experience
with and that's what most people think
of when they think of open data but
there are other sources as well
that also fall within this category
so when we're talking about government
data um there are a few different areas
that this comes into um one is
government research
so you know maybe the most classic open
data set that honestly i didn't even
really think of as open data until i
started preparing this talk
uh in the us is the census you know the
census bureau
creates these huge data sets of all
sorts of demographic characteristics of
the population
uh likewise there's a lot of public data
sets about economics
um there's a lot you know in the news
these days about public health with the
cobit 19 crisis
under other things like weather data
sets that you might not even think of as
open data
but really that's simply because they're
so essential to
you know a lot of what people rely on
every day
and then there's data about public
services that are provided it might be
police or fire or you know emergency
medical services
it might be things like education or
health care or housing
all the things that a government does to
provide services for community
you know those generally create data and
open data programs often publish that
data
so others can can use it for whatever
purposes
they see fit there's also internal
government operational data so
that'll be things like budgets or
expenditures when i work for the city of
boston uh it was an interesting time
because
you know my salary and everyone else in
in city hall you know all of our our
information about that was public record
it was published in the community
you know when i when my job was
announced um there was a
article in the boston globe our local
newspaper
that listed you know my background my
experience my title and how much money
i'm going to be
making um all that stuff is available
there's also a lot of information about
properties and this is one thing that
i think a lot of people don't quite
recognize that government is the
maintainer of but
everything about property ownership uh
valuation
transactions um and obviously in some
countries maybe this is
different um and i'm mostly speaking to
the us here but i
you know from what i've seen in a lot of
places it's similar that this is all
maintained by the government and made
available
through either open data programs
explicitly or
through um different government programs
that
then pass it on to other organizations
and then finally a key part of
open data is geospatial data you know
everything you see on a map
that you would think of as you know
street names addresses all of that is
maintained by some government agency
that's responsible for coordinating
um that kind of information and so you
know at the end of the day you might
pull something up on google maps or open
street map or
somewhere like that but you know
generally that originated with some
government planning office that decided
you know this street has this name from
this place to this place
and so all of those kinds of things as
well as all the characteristics of
things
uh around a city those are available in
geospatial data sets
so just to give a really brief uh
overview of what
an open data program looks like this is
analyze boston
it's the open data portal for the city
of boston it's actually the city's
second open data portal we released it
about a year into my time there and you
know we really
overhauled the entire program if you
dive into this site
you'll find currently as of at least
last monday they've got about 160
data sets published and many of these
update every day
as you can see here you know there's a
whole number of these that
they update on a daily basis with the
latest data they sync directly with
internal systems
you know just to pull up one of these
data sets about um electricity usage
at the central library in the city you
know this is something that's recorded
by
an internal uh electricity meter
that's stored on city computers and then
every four hours there's a script run by
my old team
that grabs that data from whatever
server it lives on
and pushes it up to our open data portal
so if you want to build some kind of
real-time monitor yourself
you'd be able to do that um as a
developer
you know anywhere in the world so what
this looks like in practice
is you know this is really raw data in
this case it's simply
a date time and the amount of of
kilowatts being drawn
at that particular point in time by the
building and
you know you have the ability to view it
online you can download a csv
or some other format or you can query an
api if you want to pull it
pull the data to build it into your own
application
so just to give a few brief examples of
what this often looks like in practice
when people use this data so this is a
project that's near and dear to my heart
it actually started out as something
that
originated from my team at city hall um
it was an idea that we had based on our
work on
our city's vision zero program which was
all about
uh you know reducing uh crash
fatalities and injuries to zero on our
streets
and we decided that you know this was
something that was broader than boston
and we wanted to build this on a sort of
open source model
so we actually partnered with a um sadly
now more or less defunct volunteer
organization called data for democracy
and this became an open source project
essentially what it does is it takes
things like crash histories around the
city
combines it with features of the various
streets
and develops a predictive model to say
what is the risk on any given street
segment
and this can be used by traffic planning
departments to
figure out what kind of interventions
you can take to minimize those risks
it's currently available for six
different cities and the team's working
to build more
you can find more information about that
at insightlane.org if you're interested
another project that came out of chicago
was about using
open data on e coli measurements at the
city's beaches to build a model to
predict where there is likely to be
high levels of of hazard at these
beaches and so
this was a collaboration with a
community developer group
where they basically built an open
source model to improve forecasts for
the beaches where they're not able to
get a recent measurement
to figure out well where should they be
paying attention to you know they didn't
have the resources to measure at every
beach every day
so they would take the measurements they
did get and use that to predict where
they should focus
next in order to improve the quality or
improve their uh knowledge about the
water quality at all these sites so that
they could
protect the public's health another
project
sadly the illustration isn't that uh
helpful right now because there's no
snow on the ground
but in syracuse they built an app an
open source tool
to take real-time information about this
the snow plowing throughout the city
and display that on a website so that
you know citizens could see where
um you know where the snowplows were
when their street was going to get
plowed um that saved a lot of you know
time and energy
for them to reach out to city hall
directly to try to ask those questions
um this is something that you know a lot
of commercial providers would make
available
but at a pretty substantial cost and
they were able to do it with open source
software
and make it freely available and this is
a project from
a a non-government group it's um an
advocacy group in san diego where they
took
government data from the census and from
state
nutrition programs and mapped where
childhood poverty was concentrated
throughout san diego county in
california
and they use that to provide an insight
for for anyone who wants to look at this
to see
you know where is poverty concentrated
and where did they need to really put
some work in
and then finally an example um that i
mentioned kind of earlier that
you know anytime you pull up a weather
app if you're pulling up pulling out
your phone you're getting information
from google or apple or whatever um you
know those organizations generally
aren't collecting weather data and
producing their own forecast
they're taking government forecasts from
places like the national weather service
in the us
or you know similar organizations in
europe and elsewhere
and so that kind of information it's not
something you typically think of as open
data but it's really a vital commodity
but so it's actually a challenge to come
up with even just five examples of this
um
because you know for the thousands and
thousands of projects that i see
produced every year
uh very few of them actually get to that
point where you have something
that's worth pointing out in a
conference presentation
and there's a few reasons why for that
and you know these
are uh problems that i think any data
scientist will see is not unique
to civic data science but is
particularly important here because some
of the unique
challenges so problem one that often
comes up is
just that people sometimes have a poor
understanding of the data or the subject
matter
or the stakeholders or users involved um
you know data scientists are notorious
for
jumping into new fields head first and
saying you know i know all this stuff
about data therefore i can solve your
fields problems
without really understanding the context
and likewise the second problem that
happens is sometimes things get built
without
what's called a theory of change you
know that is some mechanism
by which whatever's getting built will
translate into some
real world impact um often times people
think well if i do an analysis or i
build a
map or an app or a model or whatever
change will just happen afterwards
without really thinking through
what that mechanism looks like and as
part of that
the third problem comes up which is that
there's often a failure to connect
with those potential end users who can
actually build something
or do something with whatever you're
producing so for example in the case of
that
that crash prediction model you know the
end users
would be these uh transportation
departments in cities or states or
national governments who might actually
be in a place to make changes
that would say solve problems on
high-risk street segments
if you're never getting your
deliverables to those people
it's hard to see what that mechanism is
for you know actually having the impact
you're looking for
also with some of these projects you
have an over-reliance on
single individuals or small groups
who are generally volunteers and you
know not getting paid to do this and so
their availability is limited and even
if they're really enthusiastic and
committed at first
you know it's hard to sustain that over
time there's also
along the same lines you know often a
lack of quality control or refinement
where a lot of these projects make it to
the mvp stage
to the sort of minimum viable product
but they don't actually get refined to
the
level that you know they would in some
kind of commercial application and so
um you know be almost there but not
quite ready for for actual use in the
real world
and then finally after something is
built oftentimes these projects
um you get to that mvp stage but nobody
thinks about what comes next how do you
deploy it
how do you support it and maintain it
going forward and that means a lot of
these projects they get released they
get some press
and then they just kind of go away and
being able to deal with all these
problems
is really what differentiates good
projects from those who just
that we see all the time coming out of
class projects or hackathons
that never really go anywhere after the
initial development
so um you know one of the things i do
when i teach my students
data science is to really emphasize the
importance of
project design and what i mean by design
is the part of a project you do before
you ever dive into data
that you know i'd like to think of it's
like a pen and paper exercise
you know it's not something you're doing
with code uh it's really the part where
you think
through your project ahead of time and
what you're trying to accomplish here
is to think about you know what is the
purpose of your project
what is the scope of it you know what
are the things you want to do what are
the things that are outside of that
scope and and what's the final
output you also think about things like
who are the stakeholders and users
and you think about the requirements for
success and and what risks
could come up um this is often used as
an opportunity to get feedback from
whether it's your potential users
or you know some partners you're working
with or even just other data scientists
before development starts so you don't
spend a lot of time doing something
that has a foreseeable problem and it
also when you're working with a team
gives you
a shared vision and roadmap that you can
then use to drive the rest of the
development
and like i said this is important to all
kinds of data science projects
but it's particularly key for these
civic data science projects because
you know oftentimes if they start going
off in the wrong direction
they'll lose steam and never get
finished and a lot of these
issues that come up are often
preventable so
i put together 10 questions here that
are are worth asking when you're coming
up with a project design so
first one is simply what is the overall
goal you're working towards and what i
mean is
what's the real world problem you're
trying to solve you know for example in
the traffic
uh modeling or the crash modeling
application the real world goal
is to reduce the risk of crashes on
sadie streets
and then you ask who are the
stakeholders partners and users
sometimes those groups will overlap
sometimes they'll be distinct
but you need to identify them to be able
to really build to their needs
and then ask you know for these users
what do they want to know and and
how would that actually help them
accomplish that goal that you and that
you set out in the first question
it helps to remember that data science
provides value by providing information
that it helps others do their jobs
better so this is the point where you
really define
what is it what is it that would be
helpful for them to know
and then number four to get there what
inputs do you need
um and how do you get them so what are
your original data sources you know what
are the things that are available
but don't quite answer the question or
provide the information
that the users need in its current form
so then five
what follows is how do you transform
that data to get there and what does the
end result tell you
sometimes it'll be exactly what you want
in number three sometimes it will be
something slightly different or there'll
be caveats
and it's important to really understand
what it is you're producing
so then number six uh what kind of
resources do you need whether it's
time technical infrastructure support
from other people
or whatever what do you need to complete
the project
uh this is a point where you kind of do
a sanity check and say
does this make sense do i have
everything i need and what you might
find
here is well this is a good project idea
i could do it
but i need these resources that aren't
available and at that point you know
maybe you say well i'm gonna go look for
those and if i can't find them i'm not
gonna start and waste my time on
something that's not gonna eventually
succeed
so then seven this is also the time to
think about what the risks
are that could make your project fail um
it might be you know one of these
requirements isn't met
it might be that you know some
potentially
unforeseen circumstance comes up like
you know a data source that you're
counting on
suddenly goes away um in some cases that
might
you know lead you to try to mitigate
those risks in other cases
you know maybe there's nothing you can
do but at least you have a good
understanding of
well what's the likelihood of this
project succeeding or failing and does
that justify the resources needed to
complete it
number eight how do you validate the
quality of what you're producing
this is a really important thing whether
it's a model an analysis
an application or anything else because
not only do you want to make sure what
you're delivering is high quality
you want to know how you can use that
validation to build trust among these
potential end users
who many of whom probably aren't that
technical and might not instinctively
trust what you build the way you would
because you know how it
works and they don't then number nine
how are you going to provide those
results to the end users are you going
to build an application
will you be giving reports um what does
this
look like and what is what needs to come
with it in terms of training
and documentation and so forth and then
finally number 10
what happens after you've delivered um
because a project
you know is going to continue on in the
long term
and what does it take to make sure it
delivers value over time
so just two specific points i want to
delve
delve into before starting to wrap up um
one thing is about the importance of
partnerships
so it's critically important to make
sure that you find
people who know about whatever subject
area you're working in and ideally have
some ability to affect
change in that and and generally that
means people who aren't data scientists
they can help you understand the subject
matter understand your data
figure out what's actually a useful
research question to answer
a lot of times you know what data
scientists think is an interesting
finding or a useful
tool might not be for reasons that we
can't foresee because we're not on the
ground
and then also these are the people who
will put your results into practice and
so if you really want to have an impact
you need them on your side and finally
in the long term
in an ideal world it's really helpful to
try to get these people
to put the results or to put whatever
you build
into sort of long-term support on their
end rather than
requiring you to keep maintaining it
over time and so when you're working
with these partners i think
it helps to think through what their
incentives are what are their their
limitations
um and sometimes you might you know have
to look around for potential partners
where
you know maybe for example i want to
build something for boston
but the partner say in the
transportation department here
you know maybe they're too busy to help
or they're a little skeptical um rather
than just giving up that's a time to say
you know maybe i'll go over to cambridge
across the river and say
you know they might be more interested
or look at you know a smaller city even
um and that might be a way to get off
the ground where then
if you have success with them you can
come back later to boston and say hey
are you
interested now that there's something
more to show and then finally you know
be respectful of their time and
expertise
recognize their they may not be data
experts but they're experts in their own
field
and you know listen to their critiques
and feedback and be willing to change
your direction based on it
and then thinking through the long term
just remember your project's not done
when you think it's finished
you're going to need to provide support
to users provide ongoing infrastructure
there will be things that come up around
changes to data sources and
dependencies and so forth a good project
should also be monitored and quality
controlled over time
and if something goes wrong somebody's
going to need to fix it and at the end
of its life cycle
somebody's going to need to figure out
you know what happens when
you know just incremental changes aren't
enough to keep it producing value
and you know in the big picture i think
it's worth remembering that a poorly
supported project
is actually potentially a worse outcome
than nothing at all
for your partners and end users where
you know maybe what they're doing right
now isn't ideal
it's not the best possible solution they
could have but at the same time
you know maybe it's working for them and
if you were to give them some new tool
that then breaks later on that could
actually
leave them worse off than if they just
kept doing what they're doing and so
if at all possible too um the other
piece of advice i'd give
is it's ideal to have long-term support
provided by people who are
um actually getting paid to maintain it
rather than volunteers because obviously
they have an incentive um to make sure
that
you know this stays current and accurate
over time
so just to wrap up um a few final
thoughts i want to offer
uh the first is simply think about the
value proposition of data science and
you know i mentioned before that
it's really about providing information
to others to do their jobs better
um the flip side of that is you know
stay humble and remember that data
scientists
aren't generally the people who produce
anything themselves
you know they their job is to help other
people do their jobs better
and so that's really why these
partnerships really matter if you're
passionate about a specific area
i would really strongly advise you to
spend some time learning how it works
not just by diving into the data but
actually going and talking to people
reading books you know really starting
to understand the subject so you can be
an effective contributor
in terms of doing project designs um you
know i
proposed a lot of questions you should
ask it doesn't mean you have to know all
the answers to get started
but it does help to at least know you
don't know so you can have an idea in
mind of how you're going to get there
how you'll answer those questions
and as you go through a project you
should be open to
changing direction if you learn new
information or even
walking away if it's not working out the
way you planned
you know your time is valuable and in
some cases it may help to you know just
put your head down and try to power
through
obstacles but in some cases maybe not
maybe you learn something that says oh
this original idea i had
isn't really what's needed or you know
the data we have doesn't really
tell us what we thought it did and maybe
it's time to think about
you know how to spend your time uh in a
better way on some other project instead
you know thinking deliberately about
your projects helps you do that
and then finally if things do go well
you also want to think about how your
projects can scale
so you know i mentioned the the crash
modeling project where
we wanted to start it for boston then we
realized why not
do this as a general thing that's
available elsewhere
so any city with similar data can plug
theirs in and get these kind of outputs
that's really kind of the ethos of the
open source community after all
and so if your project goes well that's
a great time to think about how do you
generalize that to
other use cases so finally
all right hopefully i've sold you on the
the importance of these kind of projects
and
you know got you a little excited about
it so how do you get started well
there's a lot of different ways to get
started um you could start going through
open data sites on your own
you could talk to people who run an open
data program i would note that those
people tend to be pretty
busy and overworked and they may or may
not be available don't take it
personally if they
don't quite have time to hold your hand
through it but you can also get involved
with community groups
and work with say the people you know
who produce this data
in the different government agencies or
departments or programs
you could also connect with others in
your local pi data group or other groups
and sometimes you know depending on
where you are there'll be things like
hackathons and open data events
um you know i'm not a huge hackathon
person because
i worry sometimes that you know you're
doing the fun part of data science
but then just walking away before the
hard part comes
but it is a good way to get started and
i think the key
no matter which direction you go is just
remember to think deliberately
about what your projects you're building
and
plan for the long term think through
what it takes for it to be successful
and then you know commit to it enough to
follow through and
you know make sure it really pays off on
its full potential
so that's all i've got um i don't know
if i have questions time for questions
right now but i will be on discord
afterwards
um you can also reach me on twitter and
i've posted the slides
uh to github you can see the address hit
here so
if anything you want to go back and look
at please do
thank you thank you so much for your
talk and i'm really hoping that
this inspires some people to check out
these projects and
also give them the consideration that
they deserve to hopefully
go from purely hackathon to something
that's sustainable
um i would say if you're up for it
considering this is the very last talk
it's no issue if you run over a tiny bit
if you feel like
um having a look at the q a questions
that are currently being posted
maybe you feel like answering some of
them yeah so um the first one who comes
up with the projects in boston
um so this is a really interesting
challenge when i was at city hall where
um you know when i started what happened
generally was i had a team i came in
with a team about 20 people
and the the existing process was simply
that somebody in another department
would go to somebody on my team and say
hey can you do this and then they'd say
yes or no
and so sometimes that we ran into
problems where you know
um two people might be working on the
same thing without realizing it or
you know we just took on too many
projects because individually they all
sounded good
um but the problem was is that meant we
were over committed and weren't really
delivering
uh you know on the schedule we want to
or with the quality we wanted so what we
actually
did was put in place this analytics
project manager role there
where we had individuals on the team i
think there were there were three in
total
who were tasked with being the points of
contact to work with specific
departments
you know we had one that was working on
housing and healthcare and education
another that worked on you know
transportation and public works and
other city services
and a third we worked on performance
management and budgeting
and you know across those groups
they developed long-term relationships
with the partners and then helped them
scope out you know a portfolio of
projects that was more narrow
but was a better fit for actually
executing at the level of quality
and the timeliness that we wanted
uh another question who designs the
projects
eventually so um it really depends on
the particular project sometimes it will
be that project manager that i spoke of
will take the lead
and run through all of this and
generally you know they'll be
responsible for the general scoping and
planning of a project
but in some cases for example it might
be a purely geospatial
project and we had people on the team
who were gis experts
and in those cases you know it may just
get handed off to
those people who are specialists in that
particular area
to work directly with the partners to
plan out the project
um without much involvement from the
project manager so it really depended on
the project and the specific need
in terms of how to propose a different
way of setting up hackathons
actually a good example might be if you
were to go to the analyze boston site
that i showed earlier
it's uh the address of data.boston.gov
there's a showcases section in there to
provide examples of
work that was done with with boston's
open data and a lot of the content on
there
came from a challenge we did when we
released the new site
back in 2017. what we did is we had a
month-long
open data challenge program where when
we released the site
we uh essentially gave five different
areas
as we talked to other departments we had
you know the fire department the
environment department and a few others
that had ideas for what could be done
with the open data they were publishing
and so they put you know sort of calls
for projects out there
and then we basically gave we set up a
competition
where we gave teams um which who
in some cases were students in some
cases were community members or even
people at companies who had a little
extra time to work on things
um and and we gave we tasked them with
working on one of these five areas
and then a month later we did a full day
open data challenge showcase where we
basically had all the teams
give presentations um we had the
community
pick winners uh for various prizes uh
and overall that went really well i wish
that was something that
you know had been able to continue it's
just event organizing as
uh the organizers here know is a lot of
work um and
we weren't really set up to keep doing
that over time but what actually
was really great about that was by
giving teams the opportunity to
spend you know more than just say a day
working on a project but build it over
time and get feedback
um that made for a lot higher quality
projects
you know a lot more polished
it also gave an opportunity to connect
with the stakeholders so you know when
we when we had these presentations
we had people from the fire department
and the public schools and the
environment department
and all these others um at the events
and so that really provided a way for
them to see
you know what the point of publishing
this data in the first place could be
and
really understand the potential of the
things that could get built and some of
those things
um generally hackathon projects don't
turn into
you know long-term uh projects directly
but in a lot of cases you do see that
they get adopted
um or adapted you know by internal teams
and improved on from there so you know
we did that we certainly did that with
city hall quite a bit
um and then also at uh the syracuse
example that i showed earlier
um you know that was initially a
hackathon project that then
ended up getting brought in and they had
i believe it was a fellow on their team
um who was i think the summer fellow or
something um
you know took this and worked on it for
several months and built into a real
product
so that's often a great way to kind of
make that transition
and like i mentioned i am a big fan of
having these projects
uh eventually owned by people whose job
it is to maintain them over time
and so sometimes that's actually a
really good model for collaboration
awesome thank you so much that makes a
lot of sense
you